how's it going brooch my name is
pewdiepie
and welcome to friday
[Music]
4k where oh like his people called him
4k where
where's the lie 4k as in at least
4 kilos what shut up
i lied i always lie i'm a stinky liar
i'm sorry i told my mom i never needed
something so much
sorry about the neck but home oh no
legs gang no legs gang
oh gosh oh you're looking like
you've been through a rough time my dude
what happened fumbo wombus
i was in a car accident a few years ago
and lost mobility of all my limbs i'm up
for any jokes i make fun of myself all
the time
i don't buy like gang but a huge peepee
i respect that this but a scratch
bruh felix you i still didn't get the
meatball recipe
no
[Laughter]
you're gonna get me demonetized stop it
now
me with 0.25 in my account watching two
millionaires review a house of a
billionaire
interesting i can relate to this
[Laughter]
that was such a funny video my god see
we're not so different you and i
people say youtuber grow big and he go
bye bye to audience not me
we're the same all right what have we
got i had literally jumped out of my
skin what
jesus okay what is that why is it so
[Laughter]
spooky
because i was having fun playing
minecraft that was being silly and
stupid and rested in the heel this is
like oh
here comes the giant thing wow
you see what i mean
[Applause]
you know it's scripted too i think
that's the thing you see this thing
happening you're like alright here comes
the scripted thing
where i won't get hurt right what makes
marzah special to you
that huge booty i answered this seven
years ago he has such a
way with words hey you guys are digging
through my ready pillows what the [__]
hey hi get out of here this is dangerous
i don't like this
oh on 25th i'll publish my webtoon manga
called
tomahawk angel and i really really want
to include felix in the series
wouldn't it be funny if i say no and
[Laughter]
of course looks amazing look forward to
see it
[Music]
so in my video i said smash like if you
wouldn't buy
this house and then the exact amount of
people that are billionaires that can't
afford the house
smashed dislike coincidence
i think nine this is the quality of this
oh man linus we're shooting 12k marcus
brownlee
i shoot ak peter mckinnon and i shoot 4k
jackass shoot dead 1080p i shoot 480p
and cyber up scales it to
1080p take it or leave it [__]
but look it has youtube logo on it it's
really really good
if you're a youtuber you have the
youtube logo camera
you all don't know [__] you think knife
flipping is cool
try fork flipping hey
oh hey
he didn't eat it zero out of ten zero
me after trying to knife flip like pewds
is that one piece
here we go get a little this idiot yeah
apparently it's from death note i'm
sorry
all right you [__] anime nerds
[Music]
so this is the house for i think it's
sold for like 50
million or something stupid it's like
why let me check what happened to them
belair mansion on the verge of
foreclosure
shocking who would have thought
felix it's been over two years unpaused
me no
how dare you unpause yourself to make
this post
small pp get out of here skidero
napoleon according to the french
napoleon according to the british press
this [__]
these [__] one of the greatest
warlords
of our time and then some [__]
schmuck at the museum was like
did you know he was kind of short
shut the [__] up [__] [__]
man watching felix new videos watching
all the videos so you don't get ads
because all hiv
old videos are demonetized that's big
brain that's big brain right there well
done
this is my neighbor he's painting in my
[__]
i make gaming videos he just make gaming
videos
i review memes he must remember review
memes
i surpass 100 mil subs it couldn't
great success yeah
got him you should have posted this when
jack was on come on
you had one shot i wonder how pewds
feels about this now oh
it's another of the reddit sir you
always say that it takes too much time
to edit videos what's the reason you
don't hire an editor would it make your
life a lot easier and more comfortable
i feel like i'd be cheating my fans my
videos would lose a huge part of me i
enjoy the hard work
i want youtube to remain you yes it's a
cliche call i just want to prove that be
the biggest channel on youtube you don't
have to have a lot of money or hire
staff involved
as long as you have a camera passion you
can go as far as you want i mean i think
i know it doesn't sound like it but i
think i stayed true to that especially
comparing to
how most youtubers run their channel i
mean come on
yes i don't edit my videos anymore
obviously but i also wouldn't be able to
upload
i just wouldn't nearly enough for this
amount of time
so it's a train i think it's worked that
great with time so
i don't know if this was meant to put me
on the spot but i i i think i stay true
to myself
and this idea yeah what the [__] yeah
cyber after seeing this
what the [__] all the gifts get out of
here well now he looks like a hypocrite
i don't think i do i think it's uh i've
talked about it and i've talked about
how my
view on it has changed there's no
[__] way i would be able to upload as
much videos or for that this long of a
time if i edit it all myself
it just isn't feasible but in a lot of
ways yeah too i miss editing
i think uh i added a lot to my edits in
the past
not to say that sai didn't add a lot
either he does
he had a [__] ton but it comes from two
different people and that will always be
different it's just how it is
but yeah my point was well like look
where most youtubers how they run their
stuff
now they have producers writers editors
this whole team it's almost getting more
and more
like actual big productions which
there's nothing wrong with
i think uh there's room for both
honestly as becoming a bit
talky but you get my point what the [__]
oh man another amazing artsy
fan art i love it i love it thank you
vaguely charming
fantastic phenomenal work
felix bathroom be like that's incredible
you can [__] at last
at least more like felix and marzia yeah
uh these shoes these shoes
hey let's see how my nap skill improved
you even see me i've been twirling the
whole time
it's so addicting i can't stop doing
anything
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah so i've added cool music to it
oh i never do it with the dogs in room
okay what do you mean you had to wipe
what do you think happens to the poop
think felix think i love this so this is
a meme from
invincible it's a great show i really
enjoyed some bits from that series
is it weird that i like omniman more
than anyone is i i feel like i stand him
and i'm not supposed to
after all these years i finally had them
all
hell yeah we did it boys we did it
i will saw the shopping cart she was so
sweet i loved everyone that was so nice
to her in the comments as well
hey guys so i got this new bug zapper
today i was hoping to zap some bugs it's
really like electrical
oh god
oh come on oh come on
[Laughter]
come on two very different reactions
lola is fine i think maybe
what a bunch of bettas using souls in
their shoes
also pewdiepie no
no guys it seemed like people didn't get
the joke
i saved this video for myself
and then i forgot and then it showed up
and i tried to play it off as a joke
even though it was clear
do i have to explain everything hey and
also
yeah faders [__] vegas stop making
fun of my shoes
when my answer is different from the
whole class but the teacher says it
right it's right oh
hell yeah took me a second guy builds
a 500 million dollar house poverty in
africa
bye bye no problem such a crazy video
if you're sad don't be sad one of my
many mothers in life
i am a life guru
you are welcome you are welcome what was
your first food
tip milk what the [__] was wrong with me
jesus christ felix
technically the truth swedish people
first lane
uh-huh last name oh yeah
what up my name is kajole berger
do you do not want to go with a casual
burger
oh i can spin the knife so straw
that murdered my throat i picked a much
thicker base for it it's made of
material how much is the ten dollar
override
shut up stop it
the four horsemen of intelligence damn
romanians
know how to draw i don't know come on
i love my romanian bros from
czechoslovakia to
the west yeah and the rest
pewdiepie a minecraft youtuber ah i'll
take it you know what
that's accurate okay last week's
friday's repeat
thank you for watching hope you enjoy
i'm gonna take some days off
because i feel like it so i'll see you
back
with the full regenerated energy very
soon
thank you rufus
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [__] loop
i got something for you
[Music]
i can't see just download it for free
for free [__]
download it
i got something for you
[Applause]
you